now i changed a direction here what
would you do with a 115 million pound
lottery one i certainly wouldn't be here
uh well one couple they decided to
donate more than half of their winnings
to loved ones charity and those in need
you can't quite believe it can you but
there are some people out there i am
joined by well we should refer to her as
a super donor francis conley francis
lovely to see you very good morning
good morning lady thank you for having
me no no it is it is our pleasure and i
suppose before we get into what you have
been doing with the money i wonder if
you would take us all the way back to
the point that you won it i mean how did
you discover that you were just about to
become well one of the richest people i
will ever speak to
uh i i was sitting on a sofa
watching the telly and knitting and my
husband said i think i've got some good
news for you and he turned his laptop
around and showed me a picture of a
lottery ticket
and i said oh well if you're saying it's
good news it must be more than 2.50
and he said uh yeah a bit
i said so so what is it
and he said no we've won i said no
what have we won i don't know so he told
me and i just i think for the first time
in my life i was dumbfounded i was
shocked and i had nothing to say so we
stared at each other for about five
minutes
stood up gave each other a hug and i
said i'll go and put the kettle on
shallow
yeah you always need a nice cup of tea
at moments like you know winning 115
million quid um so let's move on from
from the initial shock and of course
when when you have that kind of i mean
we're talking about a life-changing sum
of money it's not just your life that's
been changed it's so many other people's
lives and you've gone on to kind of
distribute as i understand it what
practically half of the amount of money
that you've earned i think we're just
over 60 million now
so why
and i'm not i'm not suggesting that
charity is not a not a good thing but
you have to say the reason we are
speaking to you is i don't know that
we've seen a kind of a charitable
donation on this kind of scale before
from someone in your position that you
have been so lucky to win all this money
and and rather than you know going out
and buying you know 100 lamborghinis or
whatever it is that lottery winners do
you've shared the wealth
well we've spent quite a lot on
ourselves as well we've enjoyed our
money we've had a great time
we've never we've uh we've never worked
so hard either um we uh
my daughter every time i complain that
i'm i'm tired or i'm fed up where i'm
you know she said talk to the hand you
could be lying on the beach somewhere
doing nothing doesn't want to hear so
she makes a joke of it
um
to be fair i'm kind of surprised because
i i just assumed everybody would do that
i patrick said to me um
he always said if when we if we won the
lottery
he would never let me uh open a an email
or a answer a phone again because i'd
just give it all away it's just it's
just in my nature i think
and i
he turned around at night and he said to
me he said right that's too much money
but a lot of money you can make your
list now and he gave me a pen the piece
of paper and told me to make my list and
i did and i still have it
so what give us a few of the give us a
few of the ideas the stories um behind
the money that you you have donated away
i mean i i i can only imagine that that
must be a really uplifting feeling
knowing that you are in a position to be
able to help so many people
and then actually carrying through with
it
well uh
my sister was just about to lose her
house
and that saved that
my nephew was able to buy my mother's
house that we all grew up in and he
lives in that now which was lovely
that's that's family stories friends
i mean we had one friend we we took them
out for dinner and it was uh had a
little private dining room and he got up
and he ran around the table
whipping and
throwing his uh napkin around his head
uh we had another friend who just put
his head in his hands and
cried when we told him um
the family and friends thing was amazing
i mean i've been in tears so many times
uh the
the other gifts and bits and pieces i i
set up the kathleen graham trust in
northern ireland after my mother and i
set up the pfc trust in hartlepool which
is patrick and francis conley and
that was to help me
um because i am a bit
just give everybody and try to solve
everything and i really can't do that
we're just on that point because we're
just about to run out of time i i read
that perhaps uh patrick your husband was
just perhaps suggesting that you maybe
want to limit kind of some of the the
donations that you're making are you
guys are you guys perfectly happy
because you know i'm here if you're
looking for a replacement
no i'm sorry my husband has made my life
i had the life of a princess the entire
time i've been with him and i i
absolutely adore him i've been away for
a few days with my two friends who are
hiding behind the soap over there karen
redman karen redmond dyke and caroline
rose um and they uh
i actually i will run away three or four
days and i miss him like
billy oh already i i can't wait to be
back with him um
no yeah
it kind of was a joke that got out of
hand i um
i've obviously given away a lot and i
really do have to slow down no patrick
and i are very sensible still we
actually have a budget for everything we
sit at the beginning of the year and go
through our electric bills and our gas
bills and all that make sure that we're
you know we're not wasting any money um
i i need to save money so i can give it
more away and we agreed a budget
uh we agreed a smaller budget uh than i
had been so far and then i said to one
of the journalists i said well yeah i'm
sticking to the budget i'm just on 20 32
at the minute
um alex francis if things change with
patrick you've got my number now but i
think fair play to you this is
patrick's money as well i mean it comes
out of our joint bank account he knows
every penny i spent and if he didn't
want me to it wouldn't be done i was
going to tell you oh that's fine look
francis give our best to patrick as well
but well done you this is a fantastic
story it's nice to actually have some
good news
you take care